[Music]
okay so in the last lecture I told you
that you could beat the Shannon Nyquist
sampling rate if you randomly sampled
128 time points out of this very very
high resolution time series of this
audio signal and I want to show you now
that if you kind of naively down sampled
this uniformly so if we just do a
uniform down sampling and didn't space
these randomly in time but space them
evenly in time but at a much coarser
rate you would not at all
recover the right solution so I'm gonna
code that up because I think that will
be kind of fun so nothing really changes
except here when I am down sampling in Y
I'm what I did before was I randomly
chose these guys so this perm is a
random vector and I'm randomly pulling
those indices from from X so instead
what I'm gonna do is I'm just going to
actually I'm going to do what's 4096
divided by 128 it's 32 I'm only gonna
sample every 32 every 32nd entry of X so
y equals x of 32 : 32 : and so this is
gonna massively massively down sample X
into 128 measurements in Y but they're
not going to be random they're going to
be uniformly spaced so these are kind of
the two alternative paths okay what I
did in before is I randomly sampled in
time at a very low rate on average here
I'm sampling uniformly at a very slow
rate okay and I'm gonna show you that
this uniform uniform down sampling is
bad okay we're not going to be able to
solve for the true solution if we
uniformly down sample because we will
actually throw away information we will
a lea sour signal and we'll lose all
that rich information that we get from
randomly sampling okay so I'm literally
just just going to show the difference
between kind of what we did before this
doesn't look right
I think my positions are a little I'm
still plotting versus my Rand perm so
what I want to do is I want to create a
vector of 32 by 32 by length of X
hopefully that works okay it's not work
live coding is dangerous let's see if I
can actually get this Oh times delta T
yep okay I need that that's a massive
vector and I need to multiply this by my
delta T or divided by 4096
come on this is gonna work eventually
yes all right
okay except these points are not all
perfectly on my data actually I think
this is I think that this point does
actually go up does it yeah this is
dangerous to live code yep that point
actually went up you can see okay good
so now all of my red points are actually
overlapping you know they're on this
this white high-resolution data set but
now instead of sampling randomly which
is what you need to do and compress
sensing I'm sampling uniformly so I'm
just every you know I have this big fix
delta T and I'm just sampling every
delta T in red and you can see obviously
that if I just try to fit a fourier
solution to this I'm going to get some
like really weird low frequency stuff
and there's no way that this is gonna
find this ultra high frequency 777 Hertz
part of the signal okay at least that's
my gut feeling so now we're gonna run
our co samp algorithm down here now
remember our Sai here is this discrete
cosine transform matrix and this C
matrix tells me when I sampled now that
can't be perm it has to be again 32 by
32 by length of X I need to be very
careful or else everything's gonna break
okay
there's a chance something will still
break what did I do
okay just that and it's running the
Coase amp it thinks it has a solution
it's gonna try to find the sparseness
solution that's consistent with these
uniformly sampled and time measurements
but okay this is where again classic
Nyquist sampling Theory would say that
if I uniformly sample at 128 Hertz
there's no way I'm going to be measuring
or picking up on a 777 herte part of the
signal right I can't possibly pick up on
that and now when I plot the rest of the
signal we see that we just get garbage
basically okay so we get all of this
weird stuff here that has nothing to do
with our original signal and this is
what the reconstructed inverse Fourier
transform is just complete garbage
it doesn't match at all whereas that was
what happens when you uniformly sample
okay now if I go back and I I just go
back and and randomly sample I just want
to remind you what this looks like okay
I'm just gonna comment that out and go
back and kind of make everything the way
it was now we are not uniformly down
sampling but we are randomly sampling at
points in time so now again we have
these kind of random points in time and
so some of them can actually be quite
close to each other and we know exactly
what timing these were all taken at then
we can get away with solving for this
sparse vector with many many a much
lower on average sampling rates I think
this is hopefully run and we faithfully
reconstruct our signal we find that the
sparse vector s that has kind of this
power spectrum is the the vector s
that's most consistent with those random
and time measurements even though if I
did uniform in time it wouldn't have
worked okay now you'll notice I didn't
point this out before but you'll notice
that these amplitudes are quite a bit
off they're not really the right
amplitudes here that happens sometimes
when you find these one norm solutions
often the amplitudes are a little wrong
what I usually recommend doing is once
you find what values should be nonzero
so you find kind of the sparsity pattern
then what I would do is I do at least
squares on to those two frequencies once
we know that those are the only nonzero
entries I would then do a least square
solution to find what are the best
values of those that fits this in a
least square sense okay and then you you
get this very nice faithful recovery
okay excellent so we have shown how you
can solve this compress sensing problem
for a toy version of an audio signal or
kind of a one-dimensional signal and
time with random measurements and we've
looked at how important it is that those
measurements are actually random alright
thank you